many on the Left are taking aim at
Sweden for its refusal to completely
shut down their economy and their
country in the light of Kovan but now a
new study claims that targeted lockdowns
actually save more lives and do less
economic damage here to discuss Fox News
medical contributor and author of make
America healthy again dr. Nicole
Sapphire doctor sapphire good morning to
you
morning Steve okay so a couple of MIT
researchers looked at the numbers and
they figured that rather than lock down
your entire economy as we have here in
the United States if you simply targeted
at those most vulnerable people with
particularly over 65 you can have better
health care and at the same time you
won't overwhelm your hospitals and you
don't blow up the economy well while I
do agree with a lot of the aspects of
this MIT white paper which by the way I
have to say has not been reviewed by the
scientific community yet but it is just
a working white paper they make some
valid points in the sense that a
targeted lockdown is probably gonna be
better for the overall economic health
of the nation as well as maintaining
some of the physical health of the
nation but here's the thing Steve we
have to remember that the initial
lockdowns of March and April April that
were so restrictive was to make sure
that our health system had time to catch
up to the influx of koban 19 patients
our health systems were already at near
max capacity from flu season from
chronic illness and they couldn't take
in all of the new patients from koban 19
it wasn't just people over 65 who had to
go into the hospital we had wide variety
of Ages in our Hospital now that our
health systems have caught up we have
stocked up on PPE we have enough
ventilators now is the time that you
really do start looking at more of the
targeted approach to protect our most
vulnerable as we go into the fall those
over an age of 65 those with
pre-existing conditions and those who
may be overweight while the rest of the
people potentially get back to work
because as we saw in New York those from
ages
18 to 44 the fatality rate is about 0.18
per 100,000 people
and when one-third of the working
population are made up of Millennials it
makes sense to get those younger peoples
back out there to try and stimulate our
economy again yeah indeed let's switch
gears doctor sapphire later today the US
Supreme Court is going to hear another
case regarding the Little Sisters of the
Poor versus Pennsylvania remember during
the Affordable Care Act folks it was
mandated that companies had to provide
birth control for employees but little
sisters the poor said that flies in the
face of everything we stand for given
the fact that this portion dr. sapphire
of the Affordable Care Act is going back
to the Supreme Court what do you think
that means for the entire Act well you
know I know that we're trying to
extrapolate this into a bigger picture
when it comes to the Affordable Care Act
the constitutionality has already been
up for debate multiple times this
particular case is just a is whether or
not that they're gonna uphold the
Trump's rulings he they ruled to expand
religious freedoms when it came to the
Affordable Care Act saying not only were
churches exempt but certain religious
nonprofits were exempt and now even for
profits for exempt but we have to
remember why health insurance was made
initially in the about a century ago it
was a means to entice employees from
working at under a particular employer
at one point when we should probably be
respecting the freedom of said employer
and what they want to offer to their
employee if they're not offering
offering birth control or something of
that that the employee wants and it is
employees right to choose whether they
want to be employed there and right now
we know that there are a lot of jobs who
need people to work for their so it's
not that there are lack of jobs and so
you know my personal opinion is I do
believe that an employer should be able
to offer what they want it shouldn't be
the government saying what they have to
but it's also the right of the employee
or the person who's trying to vet for
that job whether they're gonna even
apply for that job
yep exactly so let's let's see we'll be
able to listen to the oral arguments
once again live the Supreme Court will
be streaming it it's all part of making
America healthy again which is a book on
your bookshelf right behind you at a
book on my bookshelf as well check it
out make America healthy get dr. Niccole
Safire thank you thanks Steve